"Uncatchable",
Alexandr Zhelanov
...
-Elgas, vous venez d'écrire
un livre sur l'ère
postcoloniale,
notamment en Afrique,
plus principalement en Afrique,
appelé "Les bons ressentiments".
Qu'est-ce que ça veut dire,
les bons ressentiments ?
-Le ressentiment est un peu
l'emprise du bourreau
sur sa victime,
emprise à la remorque,
en quelque sorte,
de laquelle se trouvent écrasés
tous les affects de la victime
et donc, dès qu'on rentre
dans cette logique très pernicieuse,
dans ce cercle très vicieux,
c'est qu'on est dans la réaction,
dans la plainte,
dans l'incapacité à s'affranchir
d'une forme d'humiliation,
et puis,
de son sceau qui est apposé
comme ça, sur la victime.
Et donc, c'est entériner
un statut de victime éternelle,
et donc qui ne crée pas
les ressources, en quelque sorte,
ni l'initiative,
ni l'esprit d'entreprise.
A partir du moment
où on entre dans cette logique-là,
on entérine...
pour de bon sa défaite.
Et donc, appeler ça
"Les bons ressentiments",
c'est jouer sur une fièvre mondiale,
qui n'est pas que dans les relations
postcoloniales africaines.
On est dans...
-Entre l'Occident
et le reste du monde,
si vous permettez l'expression.
-Exactement. J'avais fait
une tribune à Ouest-France,
où je parlais de la revanche
des damnés de la Terre.
-Qui est le titre
d'un livre de Frantz Fanon.
-Exact,
que je traficote un peu.
L'idée que beaucoup de populations
qui se sont senties très longtemps
exclues des festins du monde,
de tout ce que le monde
a produit comme richesses,
espaces de dialogue,
espaces de discussion,
d'interéchanges, de voyages,
tous ces gens qui ont été marqués,
en quelque sorte,
par cette forme d'infériorisation
et d'inégalité
qui frappe encore très fort,
ont tendance à jeter parfois
le bébé avec l'eau du bain,
à vouloir renverser le système,
dans ce qu'on a appelé,
dans des expressions diverses,
dégagisme,
et puis, au fondement de cela,
il y a quand même ce sentiment
de ressentiment,
d'une forme d'humiliation tue,
qui refait surface,
et dont la fièvre est comme ça
parfois assez terrible.
Et on a une autrice française,
une philosophe,
qui s'appelle Cynthia Fleury,
qui a écrit un livre,
"Ci-gît l'amer",
sur le ressentiment,
une monographie formidable
de ce sentiment-là.
En le réutilisant
dans mon titre,
c'est montrer que...
aussi loin que montent
les cris d'émancipation,
il y a encore des liens
d'interdépendance.
Il faut aller à la racine
de ce malaise, c'est pourquoi
j'ai appelé mon livre
"Les bons ressentiments".
-Alors, pourquoi "bons" ?
-Oui, mais parce que...
l'époque cultive
un ressentiment
en lui donnant une vertu,
quasiment.
C'est ça. Et puis,
dans le ressentiment,
il n'y a pas tout à jeter,
parce que...
ce que dit la victime
de ce qu'elle a subi
n'est pas contestable.
C'est ce qu'elle en fait
qui est le problème.
On peut avoir de bons ressentiments,
qui sont parfaitement justifiés.
-Lesquels, par exemple ?
-Lesquels ?
Dire que la structure coloniale
et ses survivances
et sa manière de se pérenniser,
par des biais un peu tordus,
par une certaine forme d'opacité,
d'horizontalité,
existe encore et qu'il faut...
repenser les échanges,
essayer d'en sortir,
c'est parfaitement recevable,
donc une pensée décoloniale réelle
dans sa perspective ancienne,
qui ne tombe pas
dans les mains
d'un activisme rapide, hâtif,
qui ne cherche que des ennemis,
c'est essentiel.
Et moi, je m'inscris plutôt
dans cette mouvance-là,
d'une pensée décoloniale réelle,
pas dans son expression
accusatrice,
que l'on voit en France,
qui me paraît problématique.
Donc, c'est pourquoi
réparer les failles de l'histoire
me paraît important
et dans cette mesure-là,
la notion de bons ressentiments
peut avoir des échos.
-Faites-vous
une différence
entre anticolonialisme
et décolonialisme ?
-Alors, ces sujets
sont techniques. Anticolonialisme,
ça a toujours existé.
Toute colonisation produit,
dès les origines,
son rejet, par définition,
et donc, l'anticolonialisme
a toujours existé.
Des penseurs, qui ont été
des acteurs majeurs
de la décolonisation
n'ont jamais utilisé
l'étiquette décoloniale.
Ce qui arrive,
c'est une pensée décoloniale,
avec ses ancrages,
ses perspectives historiques,
son épistémologie, sa théorie,
avec des origines
que l'on retrouve
dans les pays sud-américains,
et donc, c'est cette pensée aussi
qui voyage,
qui va aussi
avoir des tonalités,
des expressions
dans les universités américaines,
avec des termes parfois...
-La woke culture ?
La cancel culture ?
On reconstruit le passé,
c'est ça ?
Ou on l'épure, plutôt,
de tout ce qui gêne ?
-Si on prend le parti
de ne partir que sur des slogans,
des acceptions rapides,
oui, on épure.
Ces sujets sont
infiniment complexes.
Il y a des choses parfaitement
recevables et des extrapolations.
Ces extrapolations
sont très commodes
pour la poudrière
des réseaux sociaux,
ou la pensée facile de l'époque,
où très souvent,
on parle de racisés,
on parle de wokisme,
on parle de cancel culture.
Ces réalités ont
des expressions réelles.
L'intérêt d'une pensée réelle,
c'est d'aller les explorer,
les évaluer
pour ce qu'elles sont,
de ne pas tomber dans l'anathème,
la disqualification facile
de termes
qui ont des résonances.
Moi, je ne suis pas
tout à fait pour,
justement, l'épuration,
pour la propreté,
pour un hygiénisme moral.
Je ne pense pas
que ce soit productif.
Mais qu'on soit,
de la même manière,
aussi sensible aux quêtes,
à la recherche
d'une inclusion réelle,
à une pluralité,
à un universel qui embrasse
tous les horizons du monde,
c'est quelque chose aussi
que je trouve essentiel.
Et donc, dans ce débat-là,
il ne faut pas venir en arbitre
trancher de façon hémiplégique
avec des amnésies volontaires.
Il faut venir offrir la chance
du dialogue,
de la complexité
et de la nuance.
Ce sont ces notions-là qui sont
écrasées par les débats actuels.
-Dans "Les bons ressentiments",
vous avez
une formule
qui est très intéressante,
qui consiste à dire,
en gros,
les jeunes générations se voient
tellement peu d'avenir
qu'elles se réfugient
dans les remugles du passé.
Ca veut dire quoi ?
Parce que ce passé, en gros,
c'est un passé qu'elles critiquent,
y compris celui
de leurs aînés,
c'est-à-dire de ceux
qui ont été les acteurs
de la décolonisation.
-La tentation nihiliste est présente
dans la jeunesse africaine,
qui accable autant ses dirigeants
que la structure
coloniale. Ce qui est intéressant,
justement, dans cette logique,
justement,
de destitution des idoles,
et plus dans le refus,
justement,
de se mettre sous la tutelle
de structures
qu'on pense gangrénées
et condamnées,
se réfugier
dans un passé imaginaire,
dans l'illusion
d'un âge d'or,
dans l'existence d'un parchemin
qu'il suffirait de dépoussiérer
pour embrasser la prospérité,
c'est un autre mythe.
C'est un fantasme qui est entretenu
par les rentiers d'une forme
de décolonisation militante,
qui ne sert, finalement,
que les rentiers et pas forcément
l'ordre collectif.
Et ces jeunes aussi,
dans leur acte de destitution
de tout ce qui a préexisté,
attaquent
les responsables gouvernants.
Ils ne les attaquent pas
pour leurs échecs,
ils les attaquent pour intelligence
supposée avec l'ennemi occidental.
-Ils ont été
des collaborateurs.
-C'est là où la dénégation
de toute forme de responsabilité
de ces acteurs-là
produit un monde
où personne
n'est responsable de rien,
où le coupable presque tout trouvé,
c'est la colonisation,
et sa matrice.
Il ne s'agit nullement
d'exonérer la colonisation
de ce qu'elle a produit
comme violences, comme humiliations,
comme survivances,
mais ne pas tout lui prêter
ou tout lui imputer,
parce que pour le coup,
c'est oublier que les Africains
ne sont pas les acteurs passifs
de l'histoire.
Toute modernité est
une coconstruction.
Et désigner des victimes
ne doit pas aboutir,
en quelque sorte, à...
déresponsabiliser d'autres
et tenir les deux bouts
dans ce registre-là
est très compliqué,
et les jeunes Africains,
très souvent,
ils se heurtent à une réalité,
un manque d'horizon,
c'est-à-dire
qu'ils ne sont pas absorbés
par le tissu économique et social.
Chez eux, tout est assez bouché.
Et au plus fort des discours
sur la décolonisation
qui ont comme fief la diaspora,
au même moment, les jeunes Africains
ont envie, pour beaucoup,
de quitter le continent
pour aller en Occident.
Voilà le paradoxe,
voilà le paradoxe où nous mènent
toutes ces périodes-là,
qui n'ont jamais véritablement
diagnostiqué les choses
très finement,
et qui n'ont pas posé
de paradigme émancipateur réel,
parce que les discours plaintifs
créaient les conditions...
...d'accusation d'un bourreau
auquel on reste encore lié.
C'est pourquoi j'ai utilisé
le terme "les bons ressentiments".
-Comment on en sort,
de cet éternel face à face,
entre,
eh bien le colonisé et...
celui qu'on accuse de tous les maux,
c'est-à-dire le colon ?
Comment on en sort ?
-Ces choses-là touchent
à des affects,
à des blessures profondes.
Il me paraît important
de ne pas les minimiser
et les prendre en considération.
La dynamique d'empathie est,
pour le coup, très importante,
mais il faut reprendre
le sens de l'initiative.
-Oui.
-Ne pas être, justement,
à la remorque,
pour n'être finalement
bon que pour la réaction.
-Oui.
-Voilà.
La réaction, c'est avaliser
la suprématie de l'autre
dans son agenda,
auquel on vient,
finalement, répondre.
Réparer cette histoire-là,
situer les responsables extérieurs,
et les responsables endogènes,
avoir une culture du débat
beaucoup plus plurielle,
ne pas songer
à une certaine forme d'existence
d'îlots d'or,
ou d'identité pure,
comprendre que toutes les sociétés
africaines sont des mélanges,
des juxtapositions,
des fédérations d'identités,
comprendre ces dynamiques
et aller chercher partout
où le savoir peut être porteur
d'échappée collective,
il me paraît que c'est le chantier
et ce chantier-là, il faut
qu'il s'affranchisse de la frange
de la plainte perpétuelle,
qui, elle,
enferme dans le ressentiment.
En sortir, c'est reprendre
le discours sur son histoire,
pas par des narrations,
qu'on appelle des narratifs.
-C'est le nouveau mot.
-Les narratifs sont éloignés
parfois du réel.
Il faut oser affronter le réel
et puis, l'enchanter par le rêve,
par l'espoir, et surtout,
par une ingénierie économique
et culturelle. Il me semble
que sur ces aspects-là,
le bât blesse.
-Il y a les éléments.
Sur le plan culturel,
on peut pas dire...
Jamais l'Afrique n'a autant rayonné
sur le plan culturel.
Il y a une infusion, aujourd'hui,
des cultures,
parce qu'il n'y a pas
qu'une culture,
mais des cultures africaines
dans les goûts
et les modes de vie
mondialisés,
je dirais.
Alors, là, vous avez dit que
par l'innovation, par l'initiative,
l'Afrique,
les Afriques peuvent
se sortir
de ce ressentiment éternel,
mais il y a aussi,
de l'autre côté,
notamment les pays
anciennement colonisateurs,
qui peuvent changer d'attitude.
Est-ce que vous estimez,
par exemple,
qu'Emmanuel Macron a eu
quelques initiatives,
notamment le sommet franco-africain
de Montpellier, où,
pour la première fois,
il a pas invité des chefs d'Etat,
mais ce qu'on appelle
la société civile, qui était
étroitement, quand même,
sélectionnée, on va dire ?
Est-ce que ça a changé
quelque chose ?
Ca change quelque chose ?
Vous étiez à Montpellier ?
-Je n'y étais pas.
Il y a quelque chose
dans ce que vous avez dit
sur l'existence
d'une richesse culturelle,
qui n'a jamais disparu.
Elle a toujours été là.
Elle n'a été niée...
-Moins connue, quand même.
-Elle n'a été niée qu'à la défaveur
d'un récit très sombre sur l'Afrique
qui a été longtemps la matrice
dans beaucoup de médias,
ce qu'on a appelé
l'afropessimisme,
où la tonalité était
une tonalité très mortuaire.
Sur l'Afrique,
on ne parlait que d'oraisons,
mais cette richesse-là,
ce dynamisme-là,
dans les thèmes
que vous avez cités,
a toujours existé
et continue d'exister.
Les richesses des sociétés
sont consubstantielles à leur vie.
Elles ne naissent pas
comme ça du néant.
Ce sont, justement,
des éléments qui sont semés,
qui sont enracinés,
et qui fleurissent à la faveur
de contextes plus porteurs.
Ca, ça a toujours existé
et donc, c'est juste lutter
contre ce différentialisme,
qui a été
un différentialisme raciste,
et aussi lutter contre
un différentialisme particularisant,
qui est celui des anticoloniaux,
par moments,
à travers des paradigmes
qui ont été frelatés,
comme le panafricanisme
et ce qu'il est devenu.
Ca, c'est une chose.
Sur Emmanuel Macron,
moi, je suis toujours
un peu embêté par...
le manque de jonction
entre le discours et les faits,
la prétention, les scansions,
et la réalité de ces relations-là.
Il y a toujours
une certaine forme de verticalité,
et malgré les bonnes intentions,
qui sont notables, que je salue,
convier
toute une jeunesse africaine,
qui ne cesse d'accabler Paris,
aux frais de son bourreau,
pour qu'elle demande des redditions
de comptes à des gouvernements
qu'elle n'a pas élus,
un non-sens complet.
Les Africains ont élu
des dirigeants africains.
C'est leurs interlocuteurs.
S'il y a quelque chose
qui ne va pas chez eux,
ils s'intéressent à eux,
ils leur disent, mais considérer
que Paris est encore le centre
décisionnaire du discours
et du contre-discours,
que Paris a un pouvoir décisionnaire
sur les destins africains,
c'est un mythe.
C'est un mythe, parce que la France
n'est ni une solution en Afrique
ni un problème.
C'est très compliqué à entendre
pour les ambitions empathiques
françaises,
très compliqué à comprendre
pour les Africains,
mais c'est aussi simple que ça :
le rayonnement de la France
en Afrique est en train
de s'effondrer.
Les parts de marché sont
en train de s'effondrer.
La réalité, c'est qu'on est
dans une recomposition
totale,
qui n'a pas commencé aujourd'hui,
dont la perspective
est très ancienne.
Les bonnes volontés doivent être
suivies d'actes. On ne peut pas
encore, en tant que pays,
avoir une politique africaine.
-Ca ne veut rien dire.
C'est mal perçu. Et puis,
la prétention à aller faire le bien,
ça rappelle tristement
les tonalités de Jules Ferry,
aller civiliser des gens.
Et donc,
ces réminiscences de l'histoire
nourrissent encore des colères,
qui n'ont pas besoin, d'ailleurs,
d'être nourries, parce que
ces ressentiments existent.
A ce problème structurel
se rajoutent
des problèmes conjoncturels.
Les problèmes conjoncturels,
c'est ce qu'on voit en Ukraine,
dans le monde actuellement,
où d'autres puissances, à l'affût,
dans la prédation du continent,
se disent qu'il y a une place
à prendre,
quitte à mordre les mollets
de ceux
qui avaient le pré carré
et ça se passe
au Burkina Faso et au Mali.
-C'est ce que vous dites,
avec l'arrivée en masse,
ou le retour en masse,
parce qu'il faut pas l'oublier,
que les Russes,
qui étaient jadis ou naguère
soviétiques, avaient aussi
une influence énorme
sur le continent africain,
et donc là,
vous parlez des Russes
à travers les milices Wagner,
mais on peut parler des Chinois,
on peut parler des Turcs,
on peut parler des Iraniens.
Mais...
on peut parler
des Israéliens aussi.
Enfin, c'est une terre
qui est extrêmement convoitée.
C'est en cela que peut-être,
c'est le continent du 21e siècle.
Je sais pas si c'est
le continent du développement.
C'est le continent de la conquête.
-Alors, c'est...
-Une espèce...
-Mais c'est... c'est triste
pour le continent
de n'être envisagé
que comme une proie.
Il y a un livre
qui a été important pour...
ma formation intellectuelle,
le "Discours sur le colonialisme"
d'Aimé Césaire.
Césaire...
-Vous n'êtes pas le seul.
C'est pour beaucoup.
-Je crois aussi.
-Il était antillais.
-Antillais.
Et Aimé Césaire disait
que l'aventure coloniale
était une aventure aussi
de prédation :
des économies antagonistes
qui se trouvent à un moment
obligées d'exporter
leurs querelles
dans des terres nouvelles,
et c'est exactement
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui :
des économies antagonistes,
en lutte,
qui fondent comme des fauves
sur le continent,
parce que
tout le récit capitaliste
est un récit opportuniste.
Toutes les projections
démographiques,
que moi j'appelle
du démographisme,
c'est-à-dire un récit porteur
pour essayer uniquement de vendre,
c'est ce qui est en train
de se passer sur le continent.
Au moment où la France
est en train de reculer,
d'autres s'installent,
confortablement.
Et la prise d'initiative,
le récit sur soi,
avoir une certaine forme
de souveraineté sur ses produits,
est en train de disparaître,
et pour le coup,
la France est un ennemi commode,
car elle change de discours.
Sa verticalité est en train
de casser.
Elle donne des gages,
des bonnes volontés,
mais vu qu'historiquement,
elle a été l'ennemie,
elle a été la matrice intellectuelle
et que jusqu'à présent,
elle reste, justement,
le centre des décisions
de l'édition, du lectorat,
du réseau institutionnel
et culturel,
ça crée les conditions
de ressentiment.
A côté,
il y a toute une force, justement,
prédatrice, qui est en train
d'aller sur le continent,
sans état d'âme,
et résultat des courses :
aujourd'hui,
tout ce qui marche dans un pays,
comme le Sénégal,
n'est pas sénégalais.
Donc, la richesse s'est expatriée,
en quelque sorte.
-Une richesse qui vient beaucoup
des pays du Golfe,
arabique, notamment.
-C'est un monde multipolaire.
Il va partout : en Chine,
comme vous l'avez dit, en Russie,
timidement, parce que les Russes,
historiquement,
n'ont pas eu de relations
économiques privilégiées.
On oublie dans la donnée
quelque chose d'essentiel :
pendant la Guerre froide,
et même avant,
en plein développement du marxisme,
qui a élu des fiefs dans beaucoup
de capitales africaines, dont Dakar,
beaucoup de dirigeants africains
ont été formés en URSS.
-A l'université Patrice-Lumumba.
-Exactement.
Cette forme de force intellectuelle
a toujours tenu
ce discours anticolonial,
et une fois au pouvoir,
cet échec n'a pas été sondé
ou évalué.
On est dans des réminiscences
de l'histoire cruelles,
des formes de répétition,
et vous connaissez la formule :
l'histoire se répète toujours
deux fois :
la première fois, en tragédie
et la 2e fois, en farce.
La seule différence, c'est que
la farce est aussi tragique.
Et donc, on est
dans cette situation-là,
où on ne s'embarrasse même plus
de regarder les faits :
les faits deviennent embarrassants.
Il y a des discours,
des idéologies, des postures,
des regards commodes,
parce que taper sur l'Occident,
c'est la garantie de recruter
des admirateurs faciles
sur le continent,
alors que la réalité
de la présence française n'a rien
à voir avec le temps de Foccart,
le temps des colonies.
-Jacques Foccart, qui était
le conseiller Afrique du général
de Gaulle et de Georges Pompidou.
Dans votre livre, vous avez
cette formule, qui me paraît
très intéressante, vous dites :
"L'islam, élément rassembleur
"de l'anticolonialisme."
Est-ce que vous estimez
que cet islam qui, par endroits,
notamment dans le Sahel,
s'est souvent transformé
en islamisme,
eh bien, effectivement,
ça a servi d'arme,
d'une certaine façon,
intellectuelle,
d'idéologie,
contre les anciens colonisateurs ?
-A tout le moins,
un argument fédérateur,
c'est-à-dire, quand on regarde...
Moi, j'ai appelé dans mon livre
le chapitre
"La généalogie du sentiment
antifrançais, anti-occidental",
en essayant de voir la donnée
un peu multicausale de l'affaire
et donc,
j'en reviens un peu à l'islam,
c'est-à-dire, quand on regarde
les interventions françaises
dans le temps long, en Afrique,
il y a des fiefs
qui sont restés dans les mémoires.
Il y a l'Algérie.
-Mh mh.
-Dans le récit qui a été fait
de la contre-violence coloniale,
l'islam a joué
un rôle fondateur,
parce qu'il a fédéré contre,
il offrait une alternative,
un autre récit,
un kit explicatif du monde
et un kit politique
qui était, pour beaucoup,
une forme d'identité ancrée,
alors que même
quand on regarde
dans la perspective très ancienne,
cet islam n'a pas une simultanéité
avec les populations,
forcément, qu'elle prétend défendre
ou à qui elle prétend
offrir, justement,
un horizon.
On regarde aussi ce qui se passe
en Algérie dans les années 90.
-Oui.
-Avec la guerre.
-La guerre civile.
-Ainsi de suite.
Vous regardez ce qui se passe
au Sénégal, dans mon pays,
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a un livre
de Moriba Magassouba,
qui est un journaliste
qui a été à Jeune Afrique,
et qui dans les années 80
a écrit un livre :
"Sénégal et demain les mollahs",
déjà.
Et quand vous regardez ça...
-Déjà.
-Dans les années 80.
-Longtemps, on a considéré
que des pays comme le Sénégal,
les pays africains...
-Un islam soufi...
-Exactement, un islam soufi
était un rempart
contre l'avancée du wahhabisme.
Et il y a eu des chocs aussi
qui se sont produits. Il y a eu
la révolution iranienne,
voilà, qui a aussi eu
sa déflagration,
en quelque sorte, dans le monde,
donc l'islam est devenu
une forme d'identité
pour des gens aussi qui voulaient
contester l'ordre occidental.
Et donc ça, ces expressions-là,
ces ancrages, existent,
c'est-à-dire pour contrer
le discours occidental,
oui, on trouvait commode,
voilà, cette entité islamique,
qui pouvait produire
un contre-discours
et il ne faut pas oublier
que toute colonisation produit
les conditions d'une forme
de contre-violence
et de contre-récit et ce récit-là,
on le trouve partout :
dans le marxisme,
dans l'anticolonialisme.
On peut le trouver aussi
dans une version aussi de l'islam.
Et n'oublions pas
que même en Occident,
les trotskistes anglais
ont théorisé l'islamogauchisme,
avant que le terme
ne devienne dépréciatif
dans la bouche de beaucoup.
On entendait, à l'époque,
qu'il fallait faire une alliance
avec l'islam,
que le front ne devait pas
découvrir, en quelque sorte,
l'ennemi, qui était
l'ennemi occidental, sa matrice,
dans laquelle on mettait
le capitalisme et le libéralisme.
C'est ce que je raconte,
comment, justement,
l'usage d'un discours islamiste
a été aussi un argument fédérateur,
un argument de poids,
pour des populations
qui étaient émiettées
et qui n'avaient pas
les mêmes origines,
les mêmes ethnies, ni même
les mêmes ascendances spirituelles,
populations auxquelles l'islam
offrait un sceau commun,
un horizon, une devise,
une vision du monde,
qu'on peut appeler
partiellement l'oumma,
et dans l'oumma,
une fois que l'unité sera...
sera véritablement
découverte dans sa fragilité,
on verra que c'était
une alliance de circonstance,
parce que cette donnée-là,
on la voit aujourd'hui,
parce que dans tout ce récit
très porteur de l'oumma,
il y a des zones d'ombres
qui ont été très commodément mises
sous le tapis...
-Définition de l'oumma ?
Le rassemblement des... ?
-C'est la grande famille musulmane.
-Des familles musulmanes.
-Il y a un auteur sénégalais,
qui s'appelle Tidiane N'Diaye,
qui a écrit, justement,
sur la traite...
...transsaharienne et justement,
sur un racisme très, très fort,
qui existe
dans les pays maghrébins,
jusqu'à la manifestation...
-Yambo Ouologuem.
-Oui, Yambo Ouologuem
et récemment...
-C'est ce qu'il dénonce. Il dit...
Il parle de la traite orientale,
et il dit qu'elle a été...
sous-regardée, sous-estimée,
par rapport à ce qu'a été
la traite occidentale.
-Il parle de l'empire Nakem
et de la dynastie
des Saïf, de devoirs de violence.
Encore récemment,
exemple sans doute le plus parlant,
on a eu...
le président tunisien.
-Oui.
-Kaïs Saïed...
-Kaïs Saïed.
-...qui a libéré
les flots racistes en Tunisie
contre les populations sud...
-Subsahariennes.
-Voilà,
d'Afrique subsaharienne
et ainsi de suite,
révélant par là
un vieux fond,
qui a toujours existé,
que les luttes anti-occidentales
avaient, jusqu'à présent,
assez maintenu sous silence
ou sous scellés,
je sais pas
comment il faut dire,
mais en tout cas,
voilà beaucoup de réalités
qui ont eu tendance
à être occultées,
parce que la récurrence
du discours
devait uniquement
focaliser l'attention
sur le bourreau occidental.
Ca a été entretenu
aussi d'ailleurs
par une partie de la gauche
française anticoloniale,
parce que cette rente décoloniale,
elle était assez confortable,
alors que plus la rente monte,
plus cette popularité existe,
plus les populations africaines
étaient, encore une fois,
enferrées dans des logiques
d'asservissement.
-Elgas, quand vous... dansez,
vous dansez
sur quelle musique africaine ?
-Sur beaucoup.
Alors, je danse sur...
Tèsfa-Maryam Kidané...
-Kidané.
-Ethiopienne.
-Elles sont pas toutes dansantes,
les musiques.
-Mais on peut toujours danser.
"Heywete",
Tèsfa-Maryam Kidané
-Très jazzy
et on va continuer à l'écouter,
et puis, en même temps,
un auteur,
un écrivain africain,
que vous appréciez
tout particulièrement ?
-Celui que j'ai découvert
sur le tard,
c'est un écrivain guinéen,
qui s'appelle Williams Sassine.
-Oui.
-Williams Sassine, parce qu'il a eu
un destin un peu funeste.
Une étoile filante,
très talentueuse,
mais qui a été un peu boudé
par la reconnaissance
jusqu'à la fin de sa vie
et qui a écrit des bouquins
d'un humour dévastateur
et d'une justesse remarquable.
-Merci, Elgas.
-Merci, Yves Thréard.
...
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA